my name is Boyd Allen I'm a master  sergeant United States Marine Corps from  2009 on a local interpreter named Zia  risked his life helping units like  Boyd's in Afghanistan for almost three  years since coalition forces came to  Afghanistan like by 2001 everybody was  trying to learn English in that time  English had good business then a couple  of my friends came to me and asked me to  join with the coalition forces as a  translator my demo joined as an  interpreter with the United States  Marines he did so with the understanding  of he was risking his life every day for  an opportunity to become an American  just being in that part of Afghanistan  that the Taliban controlled doesn't  matter if you're an interpreter or a  civilian it's like you live in the fear  of okay am I gonna step on a pressure  plate and get blown to bits because  somebody gonna shoot me from across the  field  [Music]